je suis né à l'intérieur du sénégal
dans le bassin arachidier
et mon père à 18 enfants
et
très tôt il nous a appris durant les
grandes vacances que nous devions aller
à la brousse pour cultiver ce que nous
mangeons
donc quand les grandes vacances commence
le jour même où il va mais tout le monde
là-bas et on va cultiver
ont cultivé
ont tiré une partie pour garder nos
semences pour l'année prochaine une
partie il vendait pour acheter les
fournitures et une partie ont mangé
durant l'année
alors on était autonome j'ai parlé de 18
personnes sans compter tout ce qui vient
après vous connaissez la famille
africaine
alors automatiquement très rapidement
une comparaison avec ce qui s'est passé
dans la pandémie où la plupart
des gouvernants étaient obligés
d'acheter des pâtes du riz du lait en
poudre pour alimenter les paysans
c'est grave
alors je suis né donc dans ces
conditions
et j'ai commencé à étudier donc et je
suis parti j'ai fait l'université cheikh
anta diop de dakar je commençais à faire
l'essai en économie j'ai été orienté
là-bas automatiquement je me suis rendu
compte que c'est parce que je voulais y
avait beaucoup d'eau potable et beaucoup
de l'africa y en a beaucoup et je vous
ai dit écoute le coeur à parler le coeur
du paysan a parlé et je me suis dit
vraiment ajib fr l'ingénieur agronome
pour comprendre un peu plus ce qui se
passe
de ce point de vue
j'ai commencé à voir mais où aller pour
étudier parce qu'au sénégal il y avait à
l'époque qu'une école de supérieure
d'agronomie et je voulais faire
l'ingénierie main et j'ai découvert le
brésil
parce que j'ai vu que c'était une fille
très vert et c'est un pays aussi qu'on
connaissait à travers son agriculture
alors je me suis dit qu'il y avait à
l'époque un programme intercambio qu'on
appelait les étudiants sénégalais
pouvait aller au brésil pour étudier et
je suis parti je ne parle pas portugais
je n'avais pas de booth mais j'avais le
coeur plein et je savais que je vais
être l'égérie de rome je suis arrivé je
commençais à faire du cours de penser un
petit peu pour gagner de l'argent pour
pouvoir financer quelque quelque chose
dans ma ville en maman et après j'ai
réussi à faire le portugais je ne parle
pas portugais ont le gouvernement
brésilien a donné huit mois pour te
former est apprécié du mans qui devait
faire un test et si tu tires pas plus de
70 retourne chez toi j'ai tiré 7
alors je suis allé à l'université
fédérale gréalou au niveau de rio de
janeiro et j'ai commencé à étudier un
deuxième année d'agronomie
le jour là je n'oublie jamais dans ma
vie parce que c'était le jour où le
professeur devait parler de comment on
fait pour contrôler les maladies chez
les plantes et avait une photo où il
monte les équipements qu'il pourrait
utiliser pour pouvoir pulvériser les
aliments que nous mangeons imaginez vous
utilisez des masques sma c'était des
masques des gants de bottes il chemine
spéciale pour pulvériser ce que nous
allons manger
alors je me suis dit il ya un problème
donc on va utiliser un filtre spécial
pour manger ça
ouais comment on peut l'utiliser c'est à
cénac uniquement pour se protéger pour
pouvoir pulvériser des choses que nous
allons manger
alors j'ai aussi dire qu'il doit exister
une autre forme
de produire nos aliments et c'est là où
j'ai commencé
j'ai une boule au tournant après donc
5ème période 4e période jyles bus il y
avait une institution en face qui était
spécialiste en archéologie une
institution créée le connais au brésil
où je suis parti pour apprendre un petit
peu comment on faisait les pratiquants
la dhr écologie à permaculture
j'ai vécu ça en étudiant et quand j'ai
terminé
un homme qui dans ma vie quidam andy a
marqué tout ce que j'ai fait il
s'appelait déjà ir lopes d'almeida il
est décédé il est venu quand j'ai
terminé mes études je voulais faire la
maîtrise il me dit allez arrête
tu veux savoir sur la permaculture
avec une paire l'académie va voir où les
choses se font pour que tu puisse vivre
ce que tu as et après tu verrais tu fais
la maîtrise et je suis parti à
l'intérieur de rio il y avait au groupe
de petit agriculteur qui faisait la
permaculture je suis venu pour j'étais
venu pour faire humain j'ai fait cinq
ans avec en réalité c'est là où je me
suis formée en à dreux parce que je
vivais ce qu'il faisait je vois et les
difficultés gd à résoudre et avec cette
pratique qu'on commence à voir
réellement ce qui se passe ce n'est pas
donner des idées à travers du boulot il
faut vivre les choses
et là bas je commençais aussi avoir les
problèmes qu'ils avaient parce qu'ils
avaient beaucoup d entraide entre ans
c'est à dire ils dépendent beaucoup des
fumiers qu'ils achetaient et chaque fois
le fumier était plus cher alors un jour
je me suis dit écoute il faut qu'on
repense un peu le dessin qu'on veut
faire et c'est à travers ça que ce
projet qu'il a indiqué hélène production
abricots logique intégré et soutenable
c'est ça
c'est à dire dans un espace de 5000 m²
homero poulard au milieu en utilisant du
matériel local que nous avons il faut on
a pilé de nos têtes déjà cette idée de
le poulailler doit avoir des ongles pour
la il doit avoir des buts du ciment qui
a dit ça
mais pourquoi on suit
alors on a commencé à deux saisons le
poulet avec le matériel que nous avons
automatiquement les gens ont commencé à
à moi j'ai ça en moi j'ai ça dans ma
région on a même un ensemble avec les
jeunes du village ont construit le
poulet alors au milieu le poulailler
dans un de ces moments là après j'avais
dit pourquoi ce héros parce qu'en
réalité seulement la tête des gens qui
détruisent la nature et carré
[Rires]
noël
la nature et les roses c'est l'homme qui
a commencé à que tous ces carrés là donc
quand tu fais l'euro il ya les
interactions les espèces interagissent
et se protège il ya des plantes qui ne
donne pas des fruits mais qui
fertilisent le sol il ya des plantes
voir donc il ya toutes les interactions
qu'on favorise canton d'eymet dans
l'euro alors vous voyez comme de public
et au milieu le pool du pays ne
produisent l'engrais des heures et de la
viande et ne sont pas payés parce que là
enfants qui le relie à des pâturages
elles sortent que revienne 4 les essais
qu elle nous est dans le contrôle
alternatif des maladies
les finir l'utilisent pour fertiliser
les plantes qui sont tout autour et ce
qui reste de ces plantes et aussi une
partie de l'alimentation des poules on
ferme le sipri
alors on a fait ça le gouvernement le
rapid m'a vu et a dit et couture il faut
qu'on en fasse une politique publique il
faut qu'on en fasse quelque chose qu on
démultiplie au niveau national pour
faire ça on avait besoin de former des
jeunes
pardon
on avait besoin de former des jeunes en
immersion ya pas de bureau ce sous les
arbres dix jours on montre le monde
donne son idée un cercle
il n'a pas le patron qui vient à la
cravate qui parlent les autres écoutent
l'on est ensemble elle l'a battue je
connais pas qui est l'ingénieur auquel
les en réalité en dix jours en écoutant
ces jeunes là surgissent des têtes
surgissent des idées qui nous permettent
de faire ça
et on y arrivait en fin de compte on a
créé donc le lab et par l'indépendance
c'est à dire je ne dis même pas de la
sécurité alimentaire parce qu'on peut
avoir une sécurité alimentaire à travers
des hamburgers qui nous viennent en
chine la chine
donc nous on bat souveraineté
alimentaire c'est à dire on sait ce que
nous voulons planté ça fait partie de
nous ça fait partie de notre culture et
de notre écosystème
je vais revenir quand je vais au sénégal
alors mais tout cela en même temps que
je dis j'ai étudié en même temps que je
travaille avec ces gens je coordonné le
projet entre le brésil le sénégal aussi
sur l'appui à notre écologie au niveau
des agriculteurs au sénégal et je venais
chaque fois je venais je fais 20 jours
c'est avec mes petites habitudes et j'ai
retourné en mars 2020 je viens
l'aéroport ferme
je suis chez moi à dakar et je regarde
la télé et je vois une mobilisation
nationale pour aider les agriculteurs à
manger sinon ils vont mourir de faim ça
m'a choqué de nouveau et je suis parti
voir il faut que je fasse quelque chose
et j'ai rencontré un groupe d'individus
qui était très engagé qui avait déjà
aussi les mêmes idées qui avait tout sur
le papier d'un projet qu'on appelle
talker toluca c'est le char de la maison
et on avait besoin d'une réponse rapide
à la peau vite il répond ce qui nous
permettait de pouvoir garantir ono
estime une alimentation à ces familles
qui étaient là bas et qui recevaient des
pâtes et qu'il essaie d'aider les rangs
poudre automatiquement donc nous avons
me surpasse le taux locker
qui est une formation certifiante c'est
à dire on fait l'immersion je suis venu
dans ce groupe j'ai amené mon petit
poney de d1 ceux qui restaient et
ensemble on est parti dans le village
durant là pour vite tout en respectant
un petit peu les distances
ça se voit
[Rires]
immersion totale avec les jeunes
regardez comme je vous ai dis là c'est
le cercle tu ne vois pas que tout le
monde donnait les jeunes venaient ont
travaillé et après on les émeutes et des
certificats il fallait regarder le
visage deuxième quand il a sauvé le
certifier c'est un deal c'est comme ça
qu'on change les choses en les montrant
vous êtes fort ce possible participer en
les écoutant et on a réussi aujourd'hui
à laon certifié plus de 800 au sénégal
elle est folle et nourricière et
médicinales qu'on les appelle les tôles
au coeur d'un le premier plan on a les
plantes médicinales au sénégal ça s'est
passé comme ça puisqu'on était en
réponse qu vite dans les premiers plants
et des plantes médicinales
après les légumes appelé les légumes les
papayers et après les grands arbres que
nous pouvons pas oublier en afrique et
vous allez voir pourquoi et qui est
aujourd'hui à moins de voir ces images
sont récentes la foire commence à
s'installer et les gens commencent à
avoir les premières productions
et ces produits là le moring a hélas le
manioc ces populations de chez nous
automatiquement donc un poids mois déjà
on commençait à garantir une
alimentation saine et maintenant on est
en train de nous structurer pour la
commercialisation de l'excédent est de
les aider à les labelliser à travers un
système participatif de garantie qui est
labellisation qui ne viennent que ne
vient pas de l'extérieur mais qui dépend
de notre crédibilité
alors je veux je ne vais pas vous saisit
jeu le terminer avec slight pourquoi
parce qu'aujourd'hui la forêt la forêt
africaine tropicale nos forêts aude et
le souss qui peuvent être la base du
développement de l'afrique
new forest or la capacité de garantir
des emplois dignes pour nos jeunes il
suffit maintenant on arrête avec la
chose la plus belle qui est coupée l'art
pour vous le bois ça le bois c'est la
valeur la plus bête de l'herbe
parce que tu coupes sa mère
mais le gars des mois
le nouveau gars qui est une plante qu'on
appelle le nevada et au sénégal parce
que ça mouille pas parce que c'est très
adapté new morning à la poudre de
mauvais gars tu y vas dans les plus
grandes boîtes de rupture va aller voir
l'avant en capsules nous on les a chez
nous
on peut les transformer le pain de singe
me saoule mais buta le bio c'est des
plantes qui ont une grande valeur et
qu'on a besoin de transformer un produit
qui nous permet de créer des emplois on
ne produit que le bâti du désert le bâti
du désert à huile qui est dit mille fois
meilleur que l'huile d'olive mais qui
est là qui composent nos forêts et on ne
regarde pas ça donc ce que je laisse mon
message c'est que en ce moment où le
monde a montré ses limites a montré que
la formule qu'ils ont prises jusqu'à
présent ne fonctionne pas en termes
d'environnement je pense que maintenant
l'opportunité ouverte pour l'afrique